That is used in many ways and in a
spiritual life
fascination that we have for food and
for taste is can be a very wonderful and
exciting adventure in life.
But it can also be a distraction from
the important work of life.
All the tastes and sights and sounds of
the world are the same.
They're wonderful,
they're amazing.
They should be celebrated.
But at the same time,
uh,
we can use things like restraint and
diet as a way to give us more time and
energy to concentrate on more
impossibly,
uh,
things that we wouldn't neglect,
in our lives through the easy
distractions,
the sights and sounds of the world of
which food is,
is one of those.
So the word in Sanskrit is taught or a
steroidy.
So you,
you try to simplify your diet to reduce
it to the lowest common denominators so
that it would be nutritious.
That's one aspect of diet.
Another aspect of diet that is the most
important aspect of diet for the Yogi is
that you trying to remove all the
violence from your diet so that,
uh,
no one suffered so that your plate could
be full and that you are grateful that,
um,
that you obtain this food with the least
amount of suffering.
Each one of us causes suffering just by
being on this earth.
Um,
when we just innocently step our foot
down on the sidewalk,
we're stepping on many microorganisms
that weren't hurting us at all.
Just trying to establish little
communities.
Uh,
they're in the,
in the sidewalk and,
uh,
so a Yogi tries to be conscious of every
step in that way so that we wouldn't
cause unnecessary harm.
The same is true for diet.
Um,
many of the things that get to our plate
gets get there only through a lot of
suffering and deprivation.
And,
uh,
so a Yogi tries to remove that and,
obviously,
uh,
that if you take the sentient beings out
of your diet,
that is if you eat a vegan diet where no
animal products are included,
you're taking a large chunk of that
suffering that you've caused out of your
life.
And that removal of a selfish path in
life,
that,
uh,
awareness of how your choices impact
others changes you and it also the world
around you.
It's quite,
yeah.